understand that I don't believe the
Quran is perfect and that it's full of
contradictions.
And I'm showing you the problems with
your Quran so that you can see. So, yes,
I know the Quran is going to say Jesus
is but a servant. But then I'm telling
you how can he but be but a servant when
he comes down from Allah as his word and
as a spirit? Aren't you getting
the point that your book is full of
contradictions?
>> is what you're adding on to it. None of
this is said.
>> I I I added on to 4:171?
I added it? 4:171 is not in your Quran?
But from Allah to Mary, that does not
say all the stuff you're saying, man.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
So, if I say to you, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, let's go. I say to you the Quran
Kalamata who al-qaeda in the Muhammad.
The Quran is Allah's word cast down to
Muhammad. Would you deny the Quran came
from Allah from above the seven heavens?
It did.
Say it again.
It did. It did. But that's my point. If
I were to use that phrase for the Quran,
Quran Kalamata who
al-qaeda [clears throat]
in the Muhammad. His word cast down to
Muhammad. You say, "Yes, the Quran came
from Allah above the seven heavens." But
when that language is used for Jesus,
no, it can't mean that. Why the
inconsistency?
Because you are you're basically trying
to get at that it's like coming from the
clouds, it's coming down to the earth.
And like this is not When you say that
to someone, it doesn't mean like it's
physically on its way. It just means
it's it's here, it's revealed. So, you
mean the Quran the Quran wasn't above
the clouds somehow? It was just revealed
so the Quran didn't come from Allah from
above the seven heavens out of speech?
It's not in the mother of the book?
It what? It did, but it's
It doesn't take that it had [laughter]
to come from the sky and fall down. The
Quran So, where did the Quran come from
then?
Where did it come from if it didn't come
from Allah above the seven heavens?
It was given It was
given to the angel Jibril. And where is
Jibril? Is Jibril above the clouds? Is
he above the clouds, Jibril? Is he in
heaven somewhere?
Yeah, but he he comes to earth. So
So, you were back to square one. The
Quran does come from above the seven
heavens cuz you have an angel who's
within the seven heavens who takes the
Quran and brings it down to the earth.
So, we're back to square one. So, where
did Jesus come from?
>> destroyed? You know how this argument
can be destroyed easily? Please destroy
it. Destroy the Quran.
>> There were some verses where the prophet
had a vision or he heard a bell sound
and the angel didn't come. So, Okay, but
you you said Gabriel. Friend, do you
understand you're refuting yourself? You
mentioned Gabriel, I didn't mention
Gabriel.
Why did you mention Gabriel?
>> You're saying it has to come from the
heavens to the
>> No, you said the Quran is from above.
Okay, let's try this again. Let's try
Maybe maybe my English is not too clear.
I'll give you the benefit of that.
Is the Quran actually with Allah on a
tablet?
Hello? Yeah, can you hear me?
Can you hear me? Now you can't hear me.
Yeah, I can hear you now. Okay. Is the
Quran actually with Allah on a tablet?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I haven't read too
much about those Hadiths. I've heard of
this, but Okay, so then if you Okay,
friend, again, then why are you arguing
about points you're not certain of?
Because the Islamic view is the Quran is
there with Allah on a tablet called
Ummul Kitab, the mother of the book, and
it came down above the seven heavens to
the lowest heaven in the month of
Ramadan, and from there Jibril alayhis
salaam revealed it piecemeal to your
prophet over 23 years. I don't want to
be teaching your religion. But now,
let's put that aside. Okay, let's put
that aside, forget about it. Since we
now agree the Quran is the word of Allah
that's there with Allah above the seven
heavens. Since Jesus is the word of
Allah that's said to have come down as a
spirit, prove to me he wasn't there
before he entered the womb of Mary.
Dude, this is I I just went through this
argument with you. Okay, we're getting
nowhere. But now, let me further prove
to you Jesus is from Allah according to
your Quran, not from the earth. Is it
not true that those who die, if they're
from the earth like Adam from the dust,
they go back to the dust, right? Like
when your prophet died, they buried him,
right?
Yeah. Okay. So, can you explain to me if
Jesus is from the earth, why is it
when [clears throat] it was time for him
to leave the earth, he didn't go to the
dust, he went to Allah from where he
came? If he didn't come from Allah, why
did he go back to Allah?
Because he didn't die.
That didn't answer the question.
No, he didn't die. Allah saved him.
>> Even that doesn't answer the question.
That's a debate whether he didn't die or
not.
What I'm saying is why didn't he die and
why did he go back to Allah? Why didn't
Allah simply have him die and have him
return to the dust if he's from the
earth?
So, this is He doesn't Allah doesn't
have to do this. Allah can do whatever
he wants. He can bring him up
>> That's a that's a nice cop-out answer. I
mean, that's a nice cop-out answer. I
mean, that's how we tap answer on issues
that we can't answer, but you're not
listening. According to your own Quran,
the Quran is a book that explains
everything in detail. It leaves nothing
for guesswork because Allah will explain
everything that is mentioned in the
Quran in detail. I'll give you the
verses to show that. So then if if Allah
wanted me to know that Jesus is not from
him
and that's why he returned to him, then
why didn't Allah cause Jesus to die and
return him to the dust?
Allah gives the answer. Where? In the
Quran.
Allah raised him up to himself to save
him.
>> question. Why?
To save him from the crucifixion. Okay,
so but why did God Allah save Jesus from
crucifixion when you just read an ayah
that said the Bani [clears throat]
Israel killed many prophets?
So, why save this prophet from killing
him and take him to heaven when other
prophets he allowed them to be killed by
Bani Israel? Because
because when the Dajjal comes, he's
going to come and kill the Antichrist.
>> that got to do with
What does that got to do with
Allah allowing prophets to be killed
and yet for some reason he doesn't allow
Jesus to be killed because he could
allow Jesus to be killed and raise him
and send them back alive because even in
your Quran, don't you have resurrection
of dead people, people who died and were
raised?
Yes. So, why didn't Allah simply have
Jesus killed like all the other
prophets, then raise him to life and
send them back at the end to kill the
Dajjal even though that's not in the
Quran. So, you're not answering
questions, you're creating more problems
cuz now you introduced another problem.
Are you claiming that Allah is He
doesn't There's no way he can let him
just live? You're trying to say that?
That's not what Don't change the
argument.
No, don't change the argument. My
argument is if Jesus comes from Allah,
then it makes sense he went back to
Allah. And what do we find? He went back
to Allah because 4:171 says that's where
he came from. He didn't come from the
earth like your prophet or Adam. He came
from Allah as a spirit and went back to
where he came from. You understand my
point now?
Look, I I understand what you're trying
to get at. I think you understand what
I'm trying to say now.
I don't know what you're trying to say
to me. I don't know. You're you're all
over the place.
No, no, no. No, I'm telling you Allah
could have done that if Allah wanted to,
but he didn't. Are we Are we to
question? No, we we are to
meditate and venture into what the Quran
says
and why it says it to understand the
point of the Quran unless you believe
the Quran is a book of mishmash
incoherent babble.
Is the Quran meant to be understood or
is the Quran a book of misguidance and
confusion?
Okay, but do you Do you understand what
I'm getting at when I say that Allah
could have done that if Allah
>> understand what you're saying and I'm
turning it back against you saying,
"Friend, if the Quran mentioned
something, that means it's for you to
understand what
it's [clears throat] saying, why it's
saying it." Because the Quran says it's
a book that explains [clears throat]
everything in detail. It explains all
things fully and completely. This is the
repeated assertion of the Quran. That
means if I believe your Quran, I have to
believe that when Jesus comes from Allah
as a spirit and returns to Allah, that
that's going to be a point that I'm
supposed to understand
and derive some teaching from because
the Quran is supposedly a book of
guidance, not misguidance, that provides
absolute fully detailed exposition of
everything it mentions.
Okay.
But this is
The argument you used has no relevance
to that point.
>> It has a lot to do cuz it shows me Jesus
is no mere man, that he's the eternal
word who became flesh, agreeing with the
Gospel of John.
Tell me Okay, of the GOSPELS
OF THE GOSPELS in the New Testament,
which Gospel says Jesus is the word of
God that became flesh? Is that Matthew,
Mark, Luke, or John?
Which of the Gospels? This is in John.
And so why is the Quran agreeing with
John in saying Jesus is the word of
Allah that came down as a spirit to Mary
if God John's Gospel is wrong?
Does it say came down? You just read it.
Al-qaeda
in the Muhammad. For the love of God.
We just We just admitted it means cast
down.
No.
Did you hear what I was saying
when it doesn't have to come from the
heavens above to the earth? It doesn't
always mean that. Okay, friend, I told
you it has to mean that because then it
says a spirit from him. What else does
the Quran need to say to you that he did
come down from Allah, which is why it
says a spirit because when he was with
Allah he wasn't physical. He was a
spirit that came down from Allah to
become physical by entering Mary. I
mean, it's right there. 4:171, oh my
goodness, it's right in front of your
eyes, man. Oh my goodness.
The camel when this is the camel
>> Can you show me where it says the camel?
Okay. Let's Let's play that game.
Let's play your game.
Yeah, okay, let's play your game. Show
me where it says the camel
The camel was sent down to the earth.
Show me where the Quran says that about
the camel.
Wait, wait, say it again. I want people
to hear you. Even though camel of Allah
What do you want? I'm trying to let them
understand.
Camel of Allah cuz you're saying camel
of Allah means it belongs to Allah cuz
he created it to show that's what it
means about Jesus. Okay. Can you show me
where the Quran says the camel al-qaha
ila al-ardh? The camel was sent down to
the earth ruhun min as a spirit from
Allah. Can you doesn't say that about
the camel, right?
It doesn't say that about
Does it say that about the house of
Allah? Does it say bayt Allah al-qaha
ila al-ardh? It was sent down to the
earth.
No, no, no, it does not say that. But it
does say that ABOUT JESUS, BUT STILL
YOU'RE GOING TO LIKEN JESUS to the camel
and to the house.
Okay, I I [laughter] think I think you
understand what I'm saying, but you have
an agenda and you're trying to really
push it. You're not really You
understand what I'm saying, but
My agenda is to show you your Quran is
incoherent. Muhammad is not a prophet,
so you turn away from him and come to
your only hope of salvation, Jesus
Christ your Lord.
Can I ask you